I think you said previously that you
were hoping a writer would do something
new with the superhero format has
anything changed in the last few years
you know I feel like there were
more experimental movies with
superheroes a while back you know maybe
10 years ago than there are today
probably because they're there's so much
money and there's so much budget thrown
into so much superhero
material maybe uh you know lower budget
filmmakers and not um exploring that
genre as much um but they're definitely
saying there's audience fatigue with
superhero movies and shows you know um
and we'll see how that plays out I know
the studios and and streamers are
worried about that you know well I mean
it would take such a budget though to
pull that off except for maybe the
Greatest American Hero the TV show I
mean that was that's different you know
but most of this is just going to be
over the top special effects and and
just well I think there's room there for
someone to tell a really compelling
human drama with someone who has you
know quote superpowers and maybe does
something heroic um I think there is
room for a unique Storyteller to tackle
that uh genre and just turn it on its
head are you still bored by some of the
superhero action films of today yeah
definitely um I'm getting more bored by
them actually uh and I have been
although I used to be a huge Marvel fan
I mean I'm still a Marvel fan I still
actually collect Comics um I collect
more DC Comics than Marvel um I'm a
Batman fan
but uh I think they're put Marvel's
putting out too much stuff and I'm some
of it I'm not even bothering to see in
the theater I'm definitely not bothering
to see streaming shows um I used to
watch every one of them and there's
already been a few that I haven't really
watched which is just they're just not
compelling me um and I see a lot of the
same
tropes and you know recycled through
various movies and especially the action
I mean there's only so many ways you can
shoot and Stage uh you know Kung Fu
fight or something or a battle with two
people who can fly um it's getting a bit
stale I think but that doesn't mean they
can't turn it around it doesn't mean
they can't do something fresh in the
same way they did with like when Black
Panther came out I mean that was very
fresh it had a cultural perspective that
they hadn't had before that and there's
always the opportunity to bring
something new into that world so is it
really boiling down to story it's
lacking in story I think so story um I
do think there is a visual element that
could um could be played with um they
actually I've seen people online
criticize Marvel's color palette in
their movies they say DC movies have
better better color grading um they just
pop better visually and I never really
thought that but it might be a part of
it you know they might want to play a
little bit more with visuals um with
genre tropes
um sometimes they want to take a
character and kind of put them into a
genre that you wouldn't normally think
of um there was a Marvel show I think it
was it that one with the werewolf um and
there was like a black they shot it like
a black and white kind of old horror
movie and it kind of came and went maybe
it didn't click but um when they can do
experimentation with that I think that's
good I also think that they're relying
too much on Comedy I mean believe it or
not I want to take my superheroes more
seriously L like I don't want every one
of them to be cracking jokes and for us
to be making fun of them you know um I
know it may sound silly but like Thor is
a serious character to me you know I
don't want it constantly the whole movie
they're making fun of Thor I just think
there's there's too many jokes and and
they're falling flat a little bit what
do you want from superhero movies as a
fan and what do you want from superhero
movies as an analyst well as a fan I
think we all want to
see characters that we loved in the
comic books come to life but the thing
is fans usually want to see them come to
life how they Envision them you know um
like if there's a change of a race or a
gender you know they say that's not the
Captain Marvel I grew up with you know
um but story-wise I do think really good
writing is huge a good story is huge and
a director who can bring that story to
life is huge um I think they need to
take their world very seriously in a lot
of instances they do need to change less
from the comic book
um uh Miss Marvel was a good example of
that I was a big fan of kamla Khan um
who's the she's a Pakistani teenager who
lives in Jersey City and when she came
out in the comic books it was very fresh
they hadn't had many um superheroes of
color they hadn't had many teenage girl
superheroes and certainly not a
Pakistani Muslim in America and so and a
lot of people were up in arms like this
isn't my superhero I grew up with but I
started reading the comics and they were
really great and I really uh was rooting
for her and I really liked seeing that
culture and I but she had a very
specific backstory with how she got her
powers and they made the Disney Plus
show and they changed that and they they
changed her powers because they were
kind of close to Reed Richards A
Fantastic Four like she can grow big and
she can stretch her Limbs and stuff so
they thought that would be too close
this is what I've heard um then it' be
too close to a Fantastic Four movie when
they do that so they changed it too much
they also made um I think they kind of
had a too much of an emphasis on a um
political point in history that they
were tying in and they brought that into
her backstory and they made it an
element behind her powers and so in that
instance I felt they changed too much
from the comic book and I felt like it
diluted the story and the story elements
that made it so fun and so compelling
for me you know but I mean maybe maybe
it gathered a whole new audience of
other people who weren't uh you know
middle-aged gen xers still reading comic
books don't write for the lowest common
denominator write for your intelligence
WR something that you would want to see
right something that is
smart um that you would think was smart
and clever and compelling a lot of new
writers are like I'm just going to write
uh one of these Hollywood movies you
know these commercial Hollywood movies
they're so dumb and they have car chases
and they have uh you know they don't
adhere to physics and um they're
throwing a sex scene and some violence
and that'll make a great script right
well that's not going to impress the
readers in the business who read
hundreds of scripts you know all the
time um avoid the cliches avoid the
tropes do it your own way and uh try to
make your story stand out because it's
not like something else it's Unique but
at the same time make sure it it ticks
off certain timings or or like you said
before fits into a mold it can't just be
a free-for-all yeah I think
structurally you you want to at least
learn the industry standard form first
before you experiment with it and you do
want to be aware of it you know like I
said you don't want to write a 150 page
screenplay when today scripts are Max
120 Pages you know and most of them are
less uh so you do want to know the form
you do want know that usually act one is
around 30 pages you do want to know that
usually act two uh the end of act two is
going to be in the 80 to 90 page range
and it's usually going to involve uh the
main character really hitting bottom and
kind of the conflict spiking more than
ever and then there's a turn in the
story there's something shocking maybe
opens a Gateway they go through that
Gateway and that gets them into act
three which is new dramatic territory
and the stakes are raised and there's a
ticking time clock and we're on the edge
of our seats wondering what's going to
happen in that Climax and if they're
going to achieve their goal that may
sound like a lot uh of of you know
strictures and too generic of um
guidelines but there's actually a
million things you could do within those
guidelines and they're done all the time
by great movies and great TV shows all
genres all types of um tones and themes
subject matter I like that so yeah so
there's structure but within that
structure within each little part you
have freedom yeah and it's your job as a
writer to execute something that does
feel fresh that is surprising to that
reader um but ideally you do stay within
those structural parameters you know you
don't have to adhere to it exactly you
know if you feel like your act two ends
on page 72 and not page
90 that's okay you know I mean
ultimately it's do we want to turn the
page do we want to keep reading do we
want to keep watching this show you know
keep me
entertained